foreign
time for another star talk explainer
yeah yeah but I heard you had something
neat and you what's that well it's you
know the all the Oppenheimer craze is
happening right now and you know when
you get down to the science of that
you're talking about fission and fusion
now you know so what is the difference
between fission infusion I mean of
course I I know I already know I'm just
asking for all those people that are
going to the movie and then for other
people there's a lot of people going to
the movie and they don't even know the
difference between fission infusion I'm
just like we should not allow those
people to remain ignorant we should let
those people know the difference between
fish and infusion okay all right so the
periodic table is a sequence of nuclear
count of protons
from hydrogen just one proton helium two
protons lithium three protons right uh
you just count them up all the way and
you keep going okay
it turns out
the nuclei of atoms
store energy that's not much different
philosophically from molecules storing
energy right so
gasoline molecule stores energy it's
just sitting there as this liquid
minding its own business wait you take a
match bada bing you release the energy
that was in the molecules now that's a
fire okay so so this idea that there's
energy to be released in the atom that's
not so weird when you think about it
right right okay so the question is how
do you get access to this energy
out of the atom what we learned
slowly in the late 1800s and early 1900s
that some atoms are not stable a version
of uranium
is not stable when I say aversion it's
one that has a different number of
neutrons in the nucleus but it's still
uranium it has 92 protons in the nucleus
all right so you can vary the number of
neutrons and those are called Isotopes
an isotope is the same atom but
different numbers of of of neutrons in
the nucleus when you do that they have
different slightly different properties
right so there's a version of uranium
that
spontaneously breaks into two other
atoms
and releases energy
so that's what we call radioactivity
if an element is radioactive it is
splitting on its own and releasing
energy and the thing that it's in will
start feeling hot oh
okay
so that splitting of an atom is called
fission
okay Vision now let's go to the low end
I can't break hydrogen it's only one
proton when you're at the low end you
can cram the elements together
so that they make a heavier element
when you do that
the mass of the heavier element is less
than the sum of the parts where did the
mass go it must have been released this
energy according to whose equation
Einstein E equals MC squared there you
go energy and mass are equivalent if you
lose Mass through this phenomenon you
gain energy out the other side of the
equation
so I take
four hydrogen atoms
cram them together to make a
full-blooded helium atom which has two
protons and two neutrons if I why
doesn't have four proton two of the
protons turn into neutrons spontaneously
look at that
that's what they did oh now wait a
minute what about didn't they have a
positive charge
and now you have a neutron that has like
no charge what happened to the charge
did it just disappear what happened nope
all the budgets are kept clean in the
accounting ledgers of particle physics
so a positive charge was retained
by the emission of a positron
the anti-matter version of an electron
is so
a proton
becomes a neutron and a positron
now a positron is anti-matter hmm
so if you're anti-matter you are leading
a very risky life in a universe of
matter
because if you encounter an electron
you annihilate and become pure energy
right so not only does the nucleus
release energy
because the mass it has less Mass the
two protons and two neutrons you also
get energy from the annihilation of the
positron
okay
so
make a a long story simple
you can take light atoms cram them
together right make heavier atoms and
energy gets released
you can combine hydrogen to get helium
you can buy Helium to get carbon so
that is called Thermo it takes high
energy to do this nuclear nucleus of an
atom Fusion you're bringing them
together
thermonuclear Fusion Light Elements
become heavier that's our sun our sun
does that our sun does them every day it
converts hydrogen into helium
releasing energy
bathing Us in warmth at the high end you
split atoms and they release energy
okay you want to make a weapon that Taps
the energy of the nucleus
okay
well it takes very high temperature to
fuse hydrogen
the sun does it under high temperature
and high pressure right meanwhile
uranium is falling apart for free and
it's doing it on its own on its own it's
like I'm uranium I'm just an energy
baby
no it turns out when uranium unstably
splits it releases a neutron
well wait a minute here's something
interesting if it splits that I wait
around for the next atom to split or can
I force a split it turns out if you do
the equation one splitting atom
releasing a neutron can split another
atom so if you if you split two if two
neutrons come out that'll get split and
dense enough you don't want it escaping
the material has to be dense enough to
guarantee it's going to hit another atom
right with that and it goes from one to
two to four to eight to sixteen and you
get a run away Chain Reaction there you
go look oh my God
calculated that damn and if you if you
purify your isotope of uranium you cram
it down and you initiate that with a
trigger
you have an atomic bomb look at that so
it's you're you're looking at a
tremendous release of energy from
something very small yes and it all
happens oh and instantaneously basically
wow correct chain reaction wow yes oh my
God first of all who
how do you think of that
scientists that's what I'm saying my
people did my brethren oh if it thinks
of this this will go back who's far of a
bow and arrow right gunpowder to put in
a projectile yeah you just depend out of
a gun he thought of missile who thought
of you like you let's go back catapults
right you know this is that's amazing
yeah it's disturbingly amazing it's
disturbingly amazing correct okay so you
can get a certain amount of energy out
of that and it takes effort to purify
the uranium all right because you gotta
you need your uranium mine and they got
to make sure it does just that one
isotope because only that one isotope
will do this not the other ones this is
why you use centrifuges
why do you have a centrifuge because one
isotope is slightly more massive than
the other
and so you centrifuge it and the heavier
isotope goes to the bottom and the
lighter ones go to the top then you skim
off the top centrifuge it again and it
becomes pure and pure and purer
did you see top gun Maverick no the main
point of the film top gun Maverick is
they have to take out this underground
bunker that's purifying uranium okay
there's only one reason to to do that
because you're going to make a bomb with
it
purified uh fissionable uranium okay so
what is more powerful fission or Fusion
all right so it turns out a fusion bomb
which is what the sun does can become
way more you can make bombs of different
sizes but sky is the limit practically
with a fusion bomb okay starting with
hydrogen and you hydrogen goes to
healing but you need a it has to be
small enough and again it has to be able
to be so self-driven once you start it
okay so the bombs that were dropped over
uh Hiroshima and Nagasaki were 10 20 ish
kilotons of TNT in Fusion bombs which
came later those were not perfected
until like the you know late 40s early
50s when we were working on them and
finally tested them those are capable of
megatons of power
so instead of kilotons you have megatons
a thousand times more powerful
because apparently one bomb leveling a
city was not powerful enough in the Cold
War
and so that's why they say the 20th
century was the century the physicist
because the Cold War defined geopolitics
and the cold war came about because of
the handiwork of physicists combined
with Engineers to actually make the bomb
and so yeah there's uh
a nuclear bomb will not only uh ignite
the pulse of of of energy is enough to
sort of incinerate whatever is in a
sight line to it but then there's the
blast wave that'll completely level
anything that happens after that because
the pulse happens at the speed of light
the blast wave moves at the speed of
sound
which is slower so if you're not
incinerated the blast wave will take you
out basically wow and one of the
concerns about you want to talk about
climate change is if if you target a
city it's one thing if you target Forest
well then you incinerate the forests and
that'll put soot into the air wreaking
havoc with our climate if you do it over
cities let's take La for example where
there's all these freeways if the
freeways are made of asphalt if it's
possible for the asphalt to catch fire
yes and you literally rain fire
from the explosion correct and so that
you want to talk about further
disrupting the climate I know if you
were where the blast wave was you're not
really concerned about the climate
you're concerned about whether you were
vaporized or not but the rest of the
world would then feel this so uh this is
I mean it's an extraordinary
uh Power that we wield and we rapidly
realized we needed some way to regulate
it so we had these Test Ban treaties and
this sort of thing right and uh and now
we have Kim Jong-un
you know so what could go wrong what
could possibly go wrong oh and by the
way early in this they did a calculation
they said if we set off a chain reaction
in this bomb will that Chain Reaction
continue into our atmosphere oh right
because the water molecules in the
atmosphere this hydrogen and the water
there's hydrogen in the oceans
okay
would this start a chain reaction and
completely incinerate our atmosphere in
our oceans so you can do a calculation
and show that it's not likely
okay well that's comforting
well the problem in physics every
calculation has a statistic especially
in quantum physics there's a statistical
probability that can be vanishingly
small but if you're honest you'd report
that even though it's vanishingly small
now part of the problem is in order to
have this runaway Fusion you need the
concentration of materials for that to
happen and you don't get that in the
ocean atmosphere or the oceans right
right that's part of the problem oh man
I gotta tell you it's I I I I haven't
seen the movie but I don't want to now
no
I'm just saying I have not seen Apple
timer but I do not want to now that this
is frightening yeah and what it's all
the energy that comes at it equals mc
squared yeah and Einstein himself he's
he he so sent a letter to Roosevelt
saying I think the Nazis are working on
this we should too okay nice then we
start the Manhattan Project but then he
realized maybe you know this is not a
good thing all right plus we learned
that the Nazis were not really close to
it that was an occasion to say okay
we're done here let's resort to
Conventional Weapons and we didn't we
pursued it wow the frontier physics
damn
oh well welcome to human civilization
hey I'm gonna sleep really well tonight
yeah
unbelievable all right Chuck well you
started it with your question here this
is true I asked for this so I deserve
every bit of it all right all right
that's all the time we have that's been
another Star Talk explainer always good
to have you Chuck always a pleasure all
right until next time Neil deGrasse
Tyson here keep looking up
[Music]